thank you so much our she say
condragulations I have a bit of deja vu
because I actually was with you when you
won the first one for outstanding host
four consecutive Emmys later how does
this one stack up oh you know I my brain
hasn't really joined my body yet because
something happens when something is
significant as this occurs and I I can't
believe I'm actually putting words
together I'll tell you in a word it's
fantastic it feels so good and I just I
think of all the brilliant courageous
contestants from our show I think we've
got probably a hundred and fifty over
these years and they make this
experience so lovely and the way America
has embraced it really eaten it up I
mean it is an amazing television show
with a lot of heart and you do so much
on it what does it mean to you to not
only have built a career out of drag but
now you've built a platform oh you're
very sweet thank you for that it feels
great to create a platform for these
kids to launch their careers you know
they are known in their towns but after
our show their world wide international
superstars and they're out there right
now working they are performing they're
all performing right this very second
out there and I love that I love that
they're thriving I mean you think about
Valentina she's just here the rent cast
just won there Emmy I mean it's kind of
amazing it is amazing and they're all so
talented I am so proud of all the girls
and now you're taking an international I
mean we've got RuPaul's Drag Race UK
what can the folks across the pond
expect from this well a lot of bad
English puns that's for sure
you know Michelle visage and I we
couldn't stop saying you're all right
babe you're right you're right bye we
couldn't stop doing that or saying ello
Guvna which is in English of course I
hate that but we got such a kick out of
it but the girls in England are so much
fun it's a different it's a different
flavor but it's there it's familiar so I
think not only will the English
audiences enjoy it but I think the
American audiences will enjoy it too
speaking of American audiences you're
also going to Sin City you're building
the show live in Vegas right a Vegas
residency
we get a familiar taste of the show on
that Vegas stage as well
oh you're gonna love the show it's it's
there are new songs in the show and
there are songs that you already know
from from drag race and a lot of the
girls that you know from drag race we
will have cast members who have been on
our show live on stage it's interactive
it is so much fun you're gonna you're
gonna flip when you see RuPaul's Drag
Race live at the Flamingo Hotel I mean
it's insane
we got UK version of RuPaul's Drag Race
the Las Vegas residency Season 12 and
season five of all-stars I mean are you
fully prepared to take RuPaul's Drag
Race to season 25 and beyond I can go
out there as long as they're making
foundation and false eyelashes I will be
out there doing this so they tell you're
gonna have a job for life there's no guy
I love to work out so it's perfect it's
perfect and finally you know you've
always said that drag isn't supposed to
be mainstream but of course you're
getting this wonderful mainstream
recognition from the TV Academy how
would you say you guys are preserving
what drag culture is all about well we
still keep it dangerous I mean listen
drag is punk rock it is rock and roll
and you know there's a superficial
element of it that is very mainstream
people know it you know I all the girls
are in TV commercials and in movies and
things but the deeper level of drag
which is that we are all God in drag is
a very revolutionary punk-rock concept
and most people cannot conceive that
that that statement so for the most part
it was that the deeper level of drag
will never be mainstream and what's one
word you would use to describe this next
season of drag race oh it's sensational
oh good tease